today on the matt walsh show the biden
team is making its closing pitch to
voters and the closing pitch is
maybe not surprisingly full-blown
marxism will it work will it backfire if
it does work what does that say about
our country
also five headlines including cities
bracing for leftist rioting after the
election if i was a leftist i'd be
pretty ashamed
though if i was a leftist i'd also be
incapable of shame i guess and
a special daily cancellation today that
you're not going to want to miss
all that on the way first though a word
from rad powerbikes
you know whether you want a new way to
get around town or
get out in nature even if you got your
kids in tow you've got to try rad power
bikes it's a great way to get outdoors
without getting all hot and sweaty so
it's a lot of fun it's also just a
practical way of getting around get to
work you know you're not going to show
up at the office
dripping with sweat your colleagues will
and co-workers will appreciate that fun
and practicality it's a great
combination and you get that with this
across between a traditional bike and a
moped but it doesn't require a special
driver's license like a moped would
but that doesn't mean the thing is slow
in fact it goes up to 20 miles per hour
without
pedaling rad power bikes very affordable
as well the most e-bikes are in the
range of like three thousand dollars
these start out at just 9.99 and uh most
are under 1500 bucks
so most of them are half half of what
you're gonna pay for most
e-bikes great for commuting getting out
of the trail hauling groceries hauling
kids
whatever it is now for a limited time
rad power bikes offers flexible
financing for as low as zero percent apr
plus free shipping bikes are going super
fast so make sure you order right away
text
bike to 64 000 today and get free
shipping that's bike
to 64 000 text bike to 64
000. all right well with only hours left
before the election uh the biden harris
ticket has decided to go
all in on marxism that's their closing
pitch their closing argument
the thing they want voters thinking
about as they head to the polls on
tuesday
is this of course biden harris has
always been
all in on marxism as has the whole
democrat party for years now but
what i'm going to play for you now is
perhaps the most direct and explicit
endorsement
of that ideology that we've heard from
any major democrat who's not named
bernie sanders
so here's the video put out by camille
harris on sunday listen to this
so there's a big difference between
equality and equity
a quality suggests oh everyone should
get the same amount
the problem with that not everybody's
starting out from the same place
so if we're all getting the same amount
but you started out back there and i
started out over here
we could get the same amount but you
still gonna be that far back behind me
it's about giving people the resources
and the support they need
so that everyone can be on equal footing
and then compete
on equal footing equitable treatment
means we all end up at the same place
[Music]
okay a lot of problems here um let me
let's start with the slightly less
significant one which is what was up
with the background noise here
was that like running water it sounded
like a running water sound effect like a
stream or
something were we supposed to imagine
camella
sitting by a stream on a mountain side
imparting these teachings to her
disciples is that the vibe they were
going for because it doesn't quite work
she definitely doesn't have the soothing
voice necessary to be a mountaintop guru
in fact the voice and the message would
be much more at home in a gender studies
class maybe a workplace
tolerance and diversity seminar or
something like that
so that didn't really work but more to
the point harris says that equality
is giving people the same amount but
that's not good enough she says because
some people are starting out ahead and
so when they
get the same amount they're going to
still be ahead of those
uh who who started out behind them so
what we need she says is equity
which means we all start at the same
place and end
at the same place and i think that
basically summarizes her argument
fairly i think now let's run through all
the reasons why this is a horrifying
combination of stupid incoherent
dishonest and dangerous number one
equality does not mean that we all get
the same amount that's not
that's not what equality is legally or
in any other sense
equality under the law which is the only
kind of equality that the government
should be concerned with
means that we're all subject to the same
laws and that the law does not
explicitly give advantages or
disadvantages
to anybody which means for example
affirmative action
those laws infringe on equality under
the law they are a direct assault on
equality under the law
by design but that's what equality under
the law is supposed to mean
and that's what we should have in this
country though we don't
equality as it relates to human beings
and societies
more generally though doesn't and cannot
exist in any other form human beings are
not in any measurable or quantifiable
sense
actually equal we should be treated
equal under the law but as far as
what and who we actually are there's no
equality there equality means sameness
i'm not the same as anyone else on earth
i have a different personality
background experience
i'm either going to be dumber smarter
more hard working less hard working more
virtuous less virtuous than the next guy
none of us are equal the type of equity
harris talks about assumes
that we are all equal we're all the same
it doesn't account for any differences
in personality character intelligence
priority
virtue it just assumes that we're all at
heart
exactly the same and crucially that
we're all trying to go to the same place
in her vision of the world
everybody wants to climb to the same
mountain top to the same elevation
and the same exact destination she can't
understand that
that everyone has their own mountaintops
and not everyone is trying to get
to the top or people have a different
idea of what the top
is for them and this confusion comes up
quite a bit i think
especially with discussions of the wage
gap the wage gap is mostly a myth of
course but
whatever wage disparity does exist
between genders
it's because women and men have
different make different choices
in their careers they have different
priorities women for example are
more likely to choose jobs that give
them more time at home
they're more likely to leave the work
force entirely to raise children
harris sees this as a problem of equity
what you can't understand is that lots
of women
make that choice because that's the kind
of life they want to live
that's their priority their vision their
desire their mountaintop
it's not the same as everybody else
number two
what does she mean by get the same
amount
same amount of what and who is giving it
is this this isn't being pedantic here
it's a serious question
i honestly have no idea what this thing
is that we're all getting and who's
giving it
what does she mean money skill iq points
what are we talking about here
but of course the vagueness is the point
harris can just shout
we should all get the same amount and
undiscerning listeners will cheer yes
sounds great the same amount without
anybody stopping to ask
uh wait a second um same amount of what
number three bringing us to the most
terrifying part of the clip i think she
says
equitable equitable treatment means we
all end up
at the same place this is what's known
as equality of
outcome equality of opportunity is
usually what politicians talk about even
though that phrase and that concept is
also
vague and impossible to achieve or even
to define but
but that's one thing equality of outcome
is another thing entirely equality of
opportunity in theory means that
you know you you clear the path and let
people walk as far
down it as they want equality of outcome
means you set booby traps on the path to
stop
some people from walking too far down it
and then you take other people and you
carry them further along it
so that at the end we're all bunched up
some of us bruised and bleeding
on the same spot on the same path and
who chooses what that spot should be
who decides what our universal outcome
ought to be
who decides where we should all end up
well the government of course camilla
harris
she'll be happy to decide and as the
decider that means that she is not
herself in the same place
she's further along she has power so
everyone else
should end up in the same place but not
her she needs to be further along
so that she can turn around and decide
where the rest of us are allowed to go
how far we're allowed to go so this is
full-blown marxism
and to understand how disturbed you
should be by it
just imagine what would be required for
the government to ensure that 330
million people
all end up in the same place well you
don't have to imagine
look elsewhere in the world and
throughout history where this experiment
has been tried you will find tyranny and
death
because tyranny and death is
these are a necessary mechanism a
vehicle
for for what camilla harris is talking
about you cannot create equality of
outcome
without removing self-determination
freedom liberty creativity
everything else that makes humans human
and life worth living
see the thing is governments really
cannot force people
to be more successful than their desire
ambition and skill level will take them
government cannot create equity through
positive enforcement
the only way it can do it is to do the
one thing governments can do would just
punish
censor stifle kill governments cannot
force people to be successful
they can though steal the fruits of
success from the successful
and chop them back down to size this is
within the logistical capabilities of
the government
even if it's not within its moral or
constitutional limits
so that's what this equity will mean
that's what it always means
punishment and suppression that's the
future the democrats envision
now voters have to decide if it's what
they want as well
let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well you know i can't recommend my
pillow enough and uh you know we
we just moved as you know we moved out
here to nashville and we're staying at a
rental right now
we're looking for a house um and you
know we got a lot of stuff in storage we
had to decide
we had we had the moving truck packing
up most of our house taking it to
storage
and then there's certain items that we
could bring with us in our car
as we made the 12-hour trip out here and
one thing that we that we my wife and i
both said is we need to make sure we
bring the my pillows
and we brought those and so that's one
little slice of home that we have
um you know at the rental place so
because i
here's the thing when you get a mypillow
or any of their products but especially
the pillow itself
once you've once you've used it you you
can't you need it so everywhere you go
you have to bring it because
you once once you've once you've slept
on the my pillow it's like everything
else
you see how uh just how insufficient it
really is
mike lindell is the inventor of my
pillow mike's latest is on
latest deals on his giza dream sheets
which are made from the world's best
cotton uh giza cotton they're ultra soft
breathable
extremely durable this is another
necessity it was easy to pack the sheets
up in the car
pillows are a little bit bulkier but we
had to bring those right now the giza
dream sheets are
at two for one low price plus free
shipping
but you got to use a promo code daily
wire that should be easy to remember
uh all the my pillow products come with
a 60 day money back guarantee
you've just got to try this stuff that's
all you know you hear about my pillow
all the time
you just got to try it give it a shot i
guarantee you it'll become
a an addiction that you need it in order
to sleep just go to mypillow.com
click on the radiolistener square to
check out the
two for one low price on the giza dream
sheets plus free shipping
they're also deep discounts on all other
my pillow products you gotta go check
that out too enter promo code dailywire
or call 800-651-1148
for these great radio specials again
that's mypillow.com
all right number one wolf blitzer of cnn
posted this video of shops in dc you can
see it here
uh i don't know if he took it or someone
else did but shops in dc being boarded
up in anticipation of
unrest as the media will call it uh
mostly peaceful unrest i'm sure
on election it's it's strange how these
mostly peaceful protesters
you know even though they're mostly
peaceful you still have to board up your
windows when they come by
it's weird strange how that works i
don't know um and then wolf blitzer says
i never thought i'd see so many
buildings here in this nation in the
nation's capital boarded up on the eve
of a presidential election in
anticipation of possible unrest
and it's not just in d.c it's happening
in new york los angeles elsewhere around
the country
so sad i agree that it's sad wolf
but you never thought you'd see it well
talk to your friends over at cnn and
also yourself
i mean you know it's strange when you've
got it's weird how this works right when
you've already got
um leftist radicals who are inclined to
towards rioting and violence and then
you go and and tell them that the
president is literally hitler
and he's trying to abolish democracy and
if he's reelected it'll be the last
election
we're all going to be living in
handmaid's tale after this um and and uh
when you tell them people that who are
already inclined to violence
yeah who who could have predicted this
result who could have possibly ever
predicted it
right number two i thought this was
pretty big news here
a tweet from joe biden he says i'm not
going to shut down the country
i'm not going to shut down the economy
i'm going to shut down the virus
that's what he claims which is pretty
amazing he's going to shut down the
virus
it's that simple that easy from what i
hear there's a there's a
big red button in the white house that's
labeled
shut down virus in all caps all you have
to do is push it
shut down the virus really donald trump
has not thought to push it or refuses to
push it i don't know
so we need joe to get in there and say
hey guys uh
why don't we just push to why don't we
just get rid of the virus have you guys
thought about doing that no one thought
of it well hey just press the button
it's gone
of course in reality though biden will
not shut down the virus
because you can't just shut down a virus
it's not how viruses work
he will do the opposite really of what
he just said there
you can effectively shut down the
economy and effectively shut down the
country you can do that
which is what he will do should he be
re-elected meanwhile in more coronal
virus news the governor of michigan
continues to find new ways to defile the
constitution
she's very creative you got to give her
that here's the latest this is from fox
17 in michigan listen to their report
the state now says in order to help with
covid contact tracing starting monday
bars and restaurants will need to start
collecting names and phone numbers of
all patrons
but some say it's just another way to
single out the industry with no real
proof that they are the problem
at a time when their capacity is already
at 50 percent
again what's this data gathering if the
data is not truthful
or what is it how do we know how good it
is scott ellis is the executive director
of the michigan licensed beverage
association a group that worked with the
state on the new guidelines but he says
that does not always mean the two sides
agree he also adds
it's not appropriate to pin covet
increases on restaurants and bars
our front line servers have already had
trouble now dealing with mask and
mandating mandating people wearing masks
we went through all that we did deep you
know we did de-escalation training and
all kinds of other things
to help with that now we're taking it to
a next level we have to gather someone's
personal information
according to a new order put out
thursday the state will require
all restaurants and bars that offer
dine-in food service to maintain
accurate records of names and phone
numbers of people who eat on site
along with the date and time they walked
in we just told them look
get named phone number and write it on a
piece of paper because if the health
department calls you and says hey
so and so came in on this day or someone
came in on this date i need the lift
they have to provide it if customers do
not want to give that information
they can be refused service i know this
is treated as a
sort of an irrelevant detail these days
but they don't have the authority to do
that where is their authority to do this
where do they derive the authority to
declare that if you want to go out to
eat you have to give your contact
information
to the to the restaurant who will then
pass it along to the government
where does the state government derive
the authority to say
if you want to go out to eat in our
state we have to know exactly who you
are
and we need your personal information
well they don't of course
but this is the the health department
the health department of michigan has
declared
that they're going to do this now and so
what we've discovered over the last
six seven months is that state health
departments
are governing bodies who have unlim the
scope of their power
is limitless they can and there is
nowhere they
their power cannot touch we know the
health department in california has
already decided
if you want to have people over to your
own house your own family members to
your own house
they could tell you how many family
members they could tell you uh where on
your house
where on your property you can meet them
for how long you can meet
what you're allowed to do when you're
with them how close you can get to them
all on your own property and this is the
state health department just
unelected bureaucrats of the state
health department simply declaring
this is what it's going to be now number
three an article on studyfinds.org
says as if the chronovirus pandemic
wasn't giving americans enough anxiety
already
you may have heard there's a
presidential election this november with
political divisions reaching historic
highs the survey finds a majority of the
country believe their most stressful day
of 2020
hasn't even arrived yet the poll
examining mental health reveals 55
of americans think election day 2020
will be the most stress-filled day of
their lives
the one poll survey examined the current
mental health of 2 000 adults focusing
on the stress
caused by cover 19. nearly 6 to 10
people can't imagine being more stressed
than they already are this year
while 67 want the year to be over now
my god stop whining you babies
first of all i just want the year to be
over now
um second this this dovetails nicely
with
what we've discussed on the show on
friday people acting like their very
lives depend
on the outcome of a presidential
election like certain doom or utopia
awaits depending on which dude is in the
white house for the next four years
and as i as i said of course elections
are very important we've been talking i
talk about that all the time on the show
very important um but
i will just say if if the most stressful
day of your life
is a presidential election what that
tells me is that you have lived
one hell of an easy and probably pretty
boring life
the average human existence there should
be things happening
in your own life that create a hell of a
lot more stress
than a presidential election does
i mean i'll give you one example because
i don't think for me this would even
make the top 100
because for example every time i go out
to eat at a restaurant with four kids
that's more stressful than tuesday's
gonna be that alone
every single one of those that that all
is gonna be above
the presidential election on the scale
of stress uh number four
ilhan omar was doing a town hall with
maisie hirono so you expect stupidity of
course
you expect the stupidity level to be
turned up to about a hundred
and in this case your expectations would
be met and exceeded
here's what iohan omar had to say so of
our three branches um the the
judiciary or the supreme court has one
of the lowest
approval ratings with um
the the united states electorate and
i think it's like a 10 approval rating
um and i wonder
um what
this process does
to um a system that we need
to function and to have legitimacy
um that is now going to have
someone be part of it who's not seen as
a legitimate
appointee um certainly with the way that
the process went
with with you know the vote being so
partisan
um what what does it mean
uh for you know the the future history
of the court
let me just jump in here ilhan and
answer that question for you
number one the phrase future history of
the court
doesn't make sense just to note number
two um
the process was not at all illegitimate
it was completely legitimate
completely legal completely normal
and you know that of course which is why
you can't explain
why it was illegitimate you just feel
like it was
number three uh yes the vote was
partisan
because every democrat announced their
decision
ahead of time before the hearings even
started
to to vote against the nominee which is
the same thing they did with kavanaugh
the same thing they did with gorsuch so
yes it was a partisan vote for the
supreme court imagine that
first one in history right um what else
number four the approval rating the
supreme court is not 10
so you just made that up it's actually
58 congress which is your branch of
government
is the least popular uh
branch of government and that approval
rating i think is about 18
it's less than 20. and a lot less than
supreme court approval writing
number five though the approval rating
of the supreme court doesn't matter
anyway i don't care if it's two percent
the the opinions of the american public
shouldn't factor into the supreme
court's decisions at all
if 100 of people in america decided that
um they wanted a certain decision to go
a certain way
that should have zero impact on what the
supreme court actually does the only
thing that should matter to the supreme
court
is what the constitution says that's it
because that's their whole job
to interpret the constitution number
five
and the mcrib is back nationwide for the
first time since 2012
starting december 2nd it'll be on
mcdonald's menus across the country
nobody can figure out why exactly though
nobody can explain to me why
the mcrib may well be the greatest fraud
ever perpetrated on the american public
it might be it is literal dog
food that people will wait in line
to eat in fact it's worse than that at
least dog food is real meat
and it has some kind of nutritional
value like you could
here's my tip to you this is all i'll
say when the mick rib comes back on
december 2nd and you think i want to go
get a mcrib
because you're you're psychotic uh and
you get there and there's a one hour
long line at the drive-thru
what i would recommend is uh leave
mcdonald's
just swing by the your local petsmart
and grab
any dog food off the shelf smother it in
you know store-bought
barbecue sauce and there you go there's
the mcrib sandwich
um and like i said even even better for
you more nutritional value i would say
all right so the mick rib sandwich is of
course cancelled but let's get to the
real daily cancellation
now today for our daily cancellation we
have another exciting
double cancellation i'll be cancelling
two different people for seemingly
unrelated offenses but i have to cancel
them both today because these
cancellations are related to the
election so i have to
i have to get them in now while i still
can so i'm doubling up um
first up on the docket is lady gaga i'm
not
entirely sure what she was trying to do
here but i think the goal was to appeal
to normal working-class americans
and encourage them to vote for biden but
her impression of normal working-class
americans
needs a lot of work watch
hey this is lady gaga i'm voting for
america
which means i'm voting for joe biden
and if you live in minnesota
pennsylvania
georgia michigan florida or arizona
i encourage you to vote and if you have
a friend that lives there
tell them to vote i'm gonna be in one of
these states tomorrow
guess which one i'll be in hint i used
to live there
cheers to the 2020 election wow
okay first of all this woman was
nominated for an oscar for best actress
keep in mind
yet that's how she performs the role of
normal human
it is not convincing to say the least
she's leaning on a pickup truck
wearing some kind of camo halloween
costume with what appear to be ski boots
and all of that would be bad enough the
cringe level was already turned up
almost to the max
but then at the end there she takes one
sip of her beer
tosses it on the ground and says cheers
that is not no that's not what people do
lady gaga
take it from somebody who who lived in
rural pennsylvania until a week ago okay
if you go to like a barbecue or a party
in in pennsylvania
and somebody hands you a cold one and
you take one sip and throw it on the
ground and say cheers
you may get a number of different
reactions but none of them will be
wow this woman is just like us so
relatable
probably the reaction would just be wait
why
why'd you do that if you didn't want a
beer you could have just told me
i mean who are you stone cold steve
austin what the hell
and then you would never be invited to
another barbecue again that's probably
how that would go
now i'm wondering if maybe lady gaga
always does this when when someone
offers a toast maybe she thinks that's
what
a toast is that's what you're supposed
to do when people say cheers she's at an
anniversary party or something and
someone says let's offer a toast to the
happy couple
and lady gaga just picks up her glass of
champagne and chucks it across the room
i don't know
but this is further proof proof of two
things number one
the people who make art and
entertainment for us um in this country
make art and entertainment for the
masses have no idea who the masses
actually are
what they like and how they act and
that's obvious
just based on the content they put out
we don't even need this video for that
number two this is the danger of being a
rich person surrounded by yes men
you know apparently nobody in lady
gaga's orbit had the gumption to stand
up and say uh
miss gaga i i wouldn't put this video
out it is um
the thing is it's the dumbest thing
anyone's ever done and everyone will
laugh at you so don't do this
unless alternatively maybe there's some
noble hero in lady gaga's inner circle
who likes to mess with her by putting
these ideas in her head like hey you
know what normal
normal folks do they throw their beer on
the ground you should totally do a video
like that they'll love it put it out
there
i imagine this person if they exist was
also responsible for lady gaga
wearing a giant slab of beef to the vmas
a few years ago
so this person i've just invented is
pretty awesome
they're not canceled lady gaga is now
on to the next one i i have in in recent
days um
cancelled both dancing and i
voted selfies i've made the rules very
clear
you may not dance you may not take
photos of yourself
with your i voted sticker very simple i
don't see why these rules will be
difficult to follow
yet time and again i find that the world
somehow does not stop doing things
when i tell it to this fact causes me
great distress
especially when it's one of my own
colleagues defying me in this way
and that's why michael knowles is
cancelled because of
[Music]
this
[Music]
yes there he is dancing while he casts
his ballot
with an eye voted sticker unconscionable
behavior
the only thing that would have made that
worse if he had his like a dog named
emoji with him
you know here's the thing i have not
really worked
closely in person with other people in
years i've been deep down in my lair
like
joe biden closed off from the world
people ask me
what it will be like now that i've moved
to nashville and i'm going to be working
in an office with other people
and the answer is that it'll be fine
just as long as nobody ever does
anything that i don't want them to do
i'm very good at working with people i
think i'm a very
relatable and likable guy you know
i'm easy to get along with provided that
everything goes my way 100 of the time
and everybody follows every arbitrary
rule i happen to concoct in my head so
in that way i'm not much different from
any other millennial i guess
but this behavior from those makes me
concerned that i have emerged from my
layer into a world
that will not necessarily bend itself to
my whim
the shock of that discovery for me is
gut wrenching
so nulls is canceled and anyone else who
should fail to follow the commandments
as i set them down is also canceled
and if i have to keep canceling the same
people over and over again
if that's what i have to do then that's
what is going to happen
that's going to do it for us today um
voting tomorrow make sure you go and do
that
if you're informed and as long as you're
not dancing along the way
and i'll talk to you then godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
is turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
clayton
you